this was a rather extraordinary clip
tucker carlson was interviewed by this
guy ben smith now he works at the new
york times now uh he's a former i think
he was the ceo of buzzfeed this guy is a
is a smear merchant and and so many of
the things that are wrong with the
internet right now come out of you'll
see this guy he's a sweaty smarmy mess
and just like a squirrely little nothing
but he ran buzzfeed for many many years
and buzzfeed you remember although
remember all those years of buzzfeed it
seems like a long time ago where people
all day long would be sharing those
things on buzzfeed where you just click
things all day long do you like this ice
cream more than cookies but you click
and i honestly believe
that they were basically just tracking
all of our behaviors all along buzzfeed
was never anything that made money when
they went public it crashed because
there was really nothing there well
anyway he ran buzzfeed buzzfeed is pure
trash but what happens in the leftist
media if you run something that's trash
and you do horrible things you move on
up so he works with new york times right
now and he interviewed tucker carlson
and the reason i'm linking this to all
of this is tucker has been one of the
most and probably the only
mainstream media voice who has been
talking about the great reset talking
about all of this globalist stuff i mean
yes there are people that are not
mainstream anywhere glenn beck would be
the best example of it but i'm talking
about fox news you know on cable news
type person talking about this stuff so
ben smith interviewed tucker and mostly
it was you know tucker you're a freaking
racist
do you think that white people have some
claim on america that people of other
races don't of course not i mean first
of all i'm a christian so i think god
made everybody and therefore everyone
has equal value in his eyes that's
the essential value of every person is
the same
but the idea that i harbor some sort of
deep racial
animus is like i mean i i think there
are a lot of criticisms you could level
at me
i think sometimes i overstate case i get
pissed i can be very nasty you've been
on the receiving end of that i know you
can vouch for that
but the idea that i'm you know that i
i mean if you were to look at my texts
or listen to my personal conversations
or read my mind
you would find
no instance where i'm like i'm mad at
black people
100
of the people that i'm mad at
are
well-educated white liberals in my mind
the sort of archetype the person i don't
like is like a 38-year-old
female white lawyer with a barren
personal life
that's who yells at me on airplanes and
so i always think people are like you're
racist okay let me let me before okay
let let me
i'm not mad at black people like what
are you talking about can i just let me
let me
so you see why i showed you that video
uh because it's slightly
not on this topic but it actually is
once you peel off one layer because
tucker is the main push back against all
of these people these people that have
nothing
that that clown ben smith knows that
tucker carlson is not a racist i would
not befriend a racist i wouldn't go on
the show of a racist uh tucker does not
want there to be different laws for
black people and tucker does not want
there to be different laws for gay
people which i hating gay people is a
form of racism i think too according to
these people intersectionality it makes
weird bad fellows
but it's all that they've got all that
they've got is oh you somehow are
stoking white outrage now the funny
thing about it is they're the ones that
are stoking white outrage all the time
they're the ones who are always talking
about white privilege and how evil white
people are and the patriarchy and all
those things and then they turn to the
other people who are saying hey that's
that's not true and we don't like
identity politics and all that and they
and then they say to them hey hey you
just said something and you're the
racist even though they're the one
pushing the racism on all of us uh and
and i think that this is what the left
gets wrong about their political
opposition and that's why they're losing
i think that there is this huge swath of
people and you are right in the thick of
it if you watch this show
that are not extremists by any stretch
that are not probably not the most
traditional republicans or conservatives
you're certainly not racist you're most
likely not homophobic homophobic uh you
might be homophobic uh because you've
lived in california long enough and the
amount of hobos there you could
eventually well wouldn't a phobia is an
irrational fear it would at some point
become a rational fear
um
but we are not racist but what tucker
said right there is right who is pushing
all of this on us so you've got the
globalist layer but within america right
now it's the overly educated white
liberals i don't even mean to bring skin
color into this but it's the elizabeth
warrens it's the bernie sanders it's
everything that comes out of harvard and
yale it's these people
who
should know better they should know
better and be appreciative of everything
that is good in america
because their ancestors had to fight so
hard for it but it's klaus schwab it's
that guy brian diese it's mark rutte
it's all of these really hyper educated
elite people and why would
hyper-educated elite people want
everybody else to think that they were
racist and why would they want everyone
else to be afraid to say what they want
online because perhaps
perhaps all they're really trying to do
is hold on to power
and people have power when they realize
it do you think that might be it